riders of Icarus it's a new MMO from
free-to-play developer nexon publishers
of games like dirty bomb and maplestory
so let's discover what this game is all
about together first up is the character
creator get to pick between five classes
then customize your appearance I didn't
get to spend as much time as i would
have liked but there seems to be plenty
of options for those of you that like to
get weird with it when one of the
default presets looks like this you know
you got a robust character creator on
your hand I wasn't given a premade
character and thrown into the world to
participate in the game's main hook
monster taming you press a button to
enter a taming stance then you gotta
sneak up behind a creature and jump on
them then treated to a button pressing
minigame which if successful will allow
you to tame the Beast it's a not that
hard once tamed you can then ride the
beast as your own into battle pretty
cool you can also turn the beast into
your subservience all you around or take
its soul and place it in your armor
creepy there of course different levels
of creatures and legendary beasts
require trickier method of capture such
as jumping off a cliff onto them which
felt pretty good when I was the only one
that did successfully now what about the
combat be able to combo attacks together
to increase damage with opponents so try
and true ability cooldown combat you
expect in every MMO
you won't just spend your time on the
ground flying is a big focus of the game
you've ride dragons Fleming pegasi
whatever this is which is cool I guess
but they ain't no giant fluffy bird man
I love this thing flying seems fine but
it can be a bit slow and if you fall off
like I did it does take a while to get
back up you get to taint peace in the
sky as well which feels pretty rad
because you have to jump off your own
creature to do it the minigames still
the same bow now it's not an MMO without
raid bosses check out this guy the scale
is impressive but I had a hard time
telling if my attacks were really doing
anything we all died a very quick and
that's my experience with riders of it
Chris the Beast stuff felt fun and
rewarding when successful and the game's
emphasis on flying makes it stand apart
the combat does feel all too familiar
and there is an overall lack of visual
identity to make it stand apart in a
crowd of free-to-play games but if what
you've seen strikes your fancy you could
try it out for yourself in the open beta
july six and for more coverage check out
gamespot
you